would you kiss shut about that don't
scream at the children don't scream at
the children I think we're good
Katie do ba is Batgirl today do your
Batman voice Katie today
it's like Bart Simpson trying to be
tough it's not the best bisexuals they
get the best of both worlds buttholes
from guys vaginas from girls maybe a
bubble from the girls are down for it
but nowadays it just seems to be a porn
thing I don't really see it a lot of
girls I know I've tried it and don't
even like it that is what happened look
guys I know some of you you're gonna go
Ryan's an idiot and yeah I am there
should have been more to that sentence
it doesn't have to be you just oh
they're gonna be like that girl's hot
and cute and and smart and but this guy
is just dumb this guy he doesn't even
have a thought he's just dumb and hairy
so dumb and hairy
oh oh oh
you know maybe some of your hesitations
might be maybe they'll pull you in
slowly Hart strand by Hart strand
they'll just wrap you in the warm
embrace of indie art comic Osteen me
studios good video yeah good video we
did good yeah
I felt like we brought the right amount
of like entertaining stupidness yeah
yeah do you think he had enough sex
jokes I don't think it had any sex jokes
god damnit a lot more sex jokes if
that's pretty earth standard I just I
just don't think anything is funny
unless there's a sex you're just going
out now so today we're gonna check out
the trailer for a ball
starring the rock look at that feel that
rock solid rock solid very nice yeah
that hurt don't touch me I'm like that
now like that's so weird
that you have a thing for muscles I have
a thing about family yeah when we girl
when we girls who likes muscles I like
fat girls some one thing my girlfriend
is really disappointed me and she'll
take that as a compliment okay okay look
baby I wish you were fat home you're
closing joki you want a really corny
joke I could go for corny tortilla chip
who told you that
DC's legends of tomorrow the first look
I believe this is a CW show and if I'm
not mistaken legends of tomorrow is
actually about many of the gods from
like you know weirdness the lot like
like Shiva okay coming together uh-huh
and they so different origins of gods
come yeah they come they come together
but that's what it is they come together
they come together so the Buckeye is
there
ah there's gonna be a character that's
like really good at masturbating though
like that should be his or her specialty
cuz I can really relate why did you what
would your name be you like that the
pump the pump Peter Martin the mega
Bader the mega Peter there you go Peter
yo yo huh your son of a [ __ ] show that
to me was a good button to end on I was
like yeah he's daddy and my girlfriend
says the same exact thing about me like
we never get to the finish line and that
she laughs and goes funny how you became
tiny at the end we're going to therapy
for it women are weak I didn't feel hurt
at all are you crying crying you're
crying you mustn't expose my powers
you mustn't expose my limits if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects you can check out
Katie Dubois channel the Katie Du Bois
channel and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine
because we can get money with product
placements with enough followers so I
can be like oh here's a picture of Katie
in a bikini Shh product placement she's
holding 50/50 if you're there I want I
want your teeth supposedly a great
weight loss results yeah yeah you just
pooping out a lot of things and you get
thin and I like pooping
I like pooping Katie I'm a cougar
okay sometimes you use get the best
script ideas when you're pooping you
know whatever works 50 hey guys I'm Ryan
right I'm Jerry I'm Katie
yes week last remember you're a woman
chris pratt's three phases of Jurassic
world acting on my favorite TV host
Conan O'Brien Katie would you sleep with
Chris Pratt yeah yeah I mean I think
most people would ya know and we know
like nothing embarrassing no really
there's like nothing to banter off of
you know really strange I would call me
know he's married yeah it wouldn't stop
me would you were just not the woman I
know I'm a good girl your virginity it
was taken Q laughter it's Michael in
there I'm pretty sure Curtis Evans wants
the [ __ ] okay it's like the bass one
yeah that's really the underlying
feeling behind all this is the sexual
animal instincts okay yeah sure that's
what the film is really exploring do you
remember when AHA when he said you make
me some kind of hero and I said you
already are cap yeah that was the best
part of the reaction that was the best
part of the reaction are we going over
our reaction yeah I'd rather review our
reactions and review the trailer okay I
thought you did a nice job yeah I was
really into it yeah you were really
watching I was really late at my guard
down letting myself feel like this
cheesy emotion yeah it was good to feel
good I'm glad
Avengers jokes are so funny he's goddamn
phone it's your goddamn phone answer it
Marcus Lumi Marcus Lumi is a type of
[ __ ] that Katie likes to give to
people actually that's incorrect
no it's fully factual she will actually
go upside down and then stick her tongue
out then bite her tongue and then roll
it
do I get to sexualize you know that's an
affront Katie I have a little girlfriend
yeah boy proven Marcus Lumi you're a
good guy you are not a [ __ ] maneuver
freak even reading that they had to tone
it down in the US and UK like oh my god
what would the original look like it
look fun though when I was watching the
footage I kind of want to play you
haven't played that I haven't personally
play manhunt - I've seen footage before
yeah it looks very intense it was so fun
yeah in someone's body rip out their
guts
oh yeah like they're spying or something
yeah I wish it was like Kinect raise
your hands someone a death and rip off
their genitals should hang out more we
should hang out more
I feel like we have a lot to talk about
in plot one more thing for a different
video of the top ten form one you know
it grossed me out the anal tearing ooh
cuz you know like I should see that
video of your bodies oh yeah I can I say
one thing you could say you shoot I'm
shooting next week so I've been in
pre-production yay
cuz new videos soon I'm shooting a film
next week
oh I'm producing oh yeah so I'm sure
it's gonna be a great film thank you
you're welcome
hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Katie
Dubois so today we're gonna check out a
video from all-time tens called ten
disgusting things about the porn in
Street now if anyone knows Katie uh you
know she loves porn she loves a good
porn out everything DP gang bang banging
bang green pie gangbang she does a lot
of gangbang kind of porn not personally
but she's into it anyway let's watch
this I like to let the guests speak in
the intros it doesn't matter if that
chicks from another country or not I'm
from America so yeah there's the moral
standpoint but even a legal standpoint
it's illegal for me to be driven off to
that right yeah I don't know it's
illegal for them to produce it even with
girls from other country I shouldn't
watch it though right right but you
won't get arrested if you do I think oh
no no the moral that's the moral that's
right there's a guideline there poop
freaks me out
no no poop I don't even like it when
there's like a little poop stain in the
toilet that I know a girl left there
bothers me
Veronica knows that when she goes poop
she's a [ __ ] ninja about it I don't
know hmm I never know she times herself
two longer than two minutes are taking a
[ __ ] that's what I learned huh I'm gonna
do minutes in the bathroom they're
taking shape okay during the fact that
like some men's penises actually get
fractured that's very scary anyway any
interest I had in mind before just went
out the window right from there
oh I'm performing yourself like being a
porn star yours Yeah right you know if
things didn't work out no I know yeah
that does not sound good to me I can
recognize my family members is being
attractive but I have no desire have a
sexual situation
oh yeah there are some sexy ass hot ass
I supporting my family members but I'm
not attractive that nope you talk about
boots whoops whoops ladies if you're
watching plastic surgery is the best way
to improve yourself I mean if you're
gonna say if you believe that like let's
make it for men too
mm men don't need men are perfect woman
are flawed that is a it's Old Testament
what what please provide a quote um this
cop this made me feel good you know I'm
doing right now I'm coming for you
I am literally orgasming for you Alan
Williams right now secreting semen
because Alan you deserve the Ryan right
semen the right semen it's not always
white but it's always right rainbow
colors how do you go to the doctor
everything can you magic they did this
like in the oculus rift that's like you
put on those like that giant theme
experience that would be beautiful they
should come up with that I heard they
have it for now you know that there's
oculus rift porn this is like you really
feel like you're having sex with the
person that seems like a natural
progression though people always want
more at a porn yeah Katie walked in and
there was born on my computer it's one
of those films where violence is gonna
be a big part in enjoying this movie
like actual like blood and [ __ ] I feel
like we're gonna want I don't want some
pg-13 [ __ ] no no but I don't want to
see someone's face blown off I've
knowing I want to see like a penis get
ripped off
really I want to see like someone like
carve out their butthole first person
point of view I want to see this guy eat
a vagina no you don't like you don't
want to see that these are all the
things I fantasized about no this is
what happen again it's a porn in early
age we talked about this Katie you want
to become a camera look at the effects
eggs don't do this you can check out
Katie's channel on the Katie du bois
Channel starring Katie du Bois Dubai
what is it Du Bois okay you're right
this whole time yeah thought I've just
been walking you know
and you can follow me on Facebook
Instagram Twitter buying a periscope
she's a Twitter and Instagram yep
as far she goes in her life I mean I
only do that when the cameras when the
cameras rolling is the only time I put
you down Wow
oh stop stabbing me with your imaginary
delegate I believe it when it happens
let's see if I can make a funny about
you
Wow there is a more of a size to you
than the average person your age that's
okay I know what it's like to be more
size size more you know like down there
the penis' people don't really say
Sizemore they kind of say size less
there it's - I'm ashamed it's thin and
small they're no width someone's ever
like you got a thick dick Ryan thanks
Sizemore you really with Katie's porn
talking now this man [ __ ] you guys both
of you out key I said don't do that
there's very few compilations I watch so
usually like [ __ ] compilations or you
know threesome compilations double anal
compilations I have to jerk off with a
double anal ones that are just a little
bit more interesting because it's like
wow she can handle two penises in her
butthole
anyway animal thug life compilation here
we go jeez I've done that before I've
done that many at times I usually throw
my urine don't ask me how I do it I just
you see this is a perfect cupping of
hands right here no urine will leak
through these fingers but then how do
you it doesn't it doesn't really get he
in it there's no goals for Jeff dial
nature well it really takes us about
this
swing you know I used to play baseball I
never played baseball I don't even know
the rules of baseball genie photo
reaction here we go that's my dick
Veronica and I were having fun I hope
that wasn't actually no wasn't my
vitamin do you want to see again
no I'm good but it was a dick actually
you know what happened um I sent a
picture to Veronica yeah and then
apparently uploaded on yeah all right
that is nowhere near a bikini whatever
it's a beautiful photo and put one up if
you put one up you have to go that's
true you get the full bikini bod I mean
you do look pretty in the photo look
very pretty premium peachy you still
worried if you saw my penis or was there
another person's penis I don't know I
don't know
doesn't matter it's not but I mean did
you take a look I mean was it a good
size I'm like I honestly just say yes
like just say yes worse of course it was
it was my picture ah Veronica yeah there
was something before that car crash that
really triggered these actions that he
took upon yeah it could have been
anything that you know something six
months from that accident could have
triggered it oh god I can only imagine
him like if I wouldn't not get a sexual
excitement at all if I saw that car
crash oh I mean if it was like a woman
in a bikini with big tits and she came
out of the car alive no damage and was
like like walking around beautiful like
oh please carry me to safety
yeah exactly okay but that's like a word
that in a different genre I know this is
called reality fair that's the
prostitute is yeah to the arrest yeah
you know escape somehow even though she
was handcuffed said good job her I've
never killed anyone but I've had many
prostitutes in my life escape I didn't
try to kill them they saw that picture
of my
yes and they just they fled they fled
and I would run after me like no there
was a bad picture that day I was off
it's always the black prostitutes
they're the number one prostitute I
ain't and I'm not racist I want a black
bra so I don't know if that played a
part of my life of being fascinated with
violence so I think it's at a certain
age we all sort of got like I was
fascinated with the Titanic yeah who's
everyone died and it's like I think you
kind of have to learn how to process
stuff and like mass death and like
horrifying circumstances yeah but there
are people most people learn how to
process that mm-hmm
these people not so much I haven't
thought about that guy's head being
blown off like ever just let it just
lock it up put it away just denial is
the only way to truly deal with your
problem yeah I do pod on the cage blah
channel get joke dick to pod that sounds
like I'm telling people to jerk off to
you she doesn't like penis I say that
every day
hello guys Ryan the right here and Katie
dubov Katherine du Bois Kate it's Kate
Katie yeah cause we're friends Katie
because you know that yeah yeah it's a
personal vibe on this channel and they
always shoot them like handheld and AH I
wanna like like just yeah get in there I
want it to happen to my balls
all right so um
Rago rageh you know the great what if
theory actually came from Russia from
the Stanislavski system who is the
godfather of method acting he was the
first person to introduce what if into
the culture before that it was all like
weird gestures on the stage but after
what if people actually started saying
okay like let's make movies let's make
theater like real life instead of like
puppetry the more you know well look
crap load of crap that's not what you
bring me on this show no no should I
like more cleavage is what's necessary
yeah Wow combination of that ripping my
balls off
yeah that was great full contact one day
we'll actually review the video watch
catherine du bois follow her on her
facebook katie operate on instagram
mm-hmm
what's your Twitter you never find you
Katie du Bois mm-hmm I think we're
friends though
do you want to know how to get girls
it's this simple hey I have a youtube
channel I'm really trying to get at
places you want to guess start and
that's how Ryan met Katie met and
every other female I know and then
somehow you just convinced them to do
YouTube and then you just keep doing
more YouTube videos although no I'm not
a beautiful friendship purchase
I think I'm gonna play yes and with you
on that come on yes and for back support
Katie and I are gonna try to just talk
to you guys look directly in the camera
I know you love it when youtubers do
that even while we're in conversation
trying to just look at you real
conversation we're having right now she
guest-starred in a web series that just
launched on YouTube called me you him
and she's in three of the episodes
it's a funny show it starts three black
guys
which is cool it's really cool yeah
right that's the way to not sound that
you're you're getting there malucia
you're one handsome devil you were one
handsome devil there's a problem though
my girlfriend likes Hispanic guys a lot
yeah I mean that's her favorite thing I
don't know why I'm assuming that but
that's that's her thing and you look
like a really good-looking Hispanic guy
and my girlfriend's half Mexican you two
are gonna be attracted to each other
sure what I want two three some of the
both of you maybe who knows chances of
that happening
not likely she's not down for something
like that so she's gonna leave me for
you I don't know if I could have you on
this channel and regain sorry
I'm trying not to jump to conclusions
these days but I can't help her just
remember what we talked about okay deep
breathing
that was really good I was really
peaceful namaste Cohen and randomly came
on and I was like a really sad dude back
then granted I want funniest kid in
junior high but that's besides the point
I'm asked it all my hilarious humor with
you know I'm s the depression thank you
yeah we bring that I was waving Jesus so
in school I would say yeah when I'm
feeling down I watch Conan O'Brien I
would call it my combs own medication
Wow what's your master impression my
Katie impression I come across
appropriate but really I have a dirty
mind oh right
I like to be a little mysterious
unsubtle the quirky that's great that's
what I put on my you know my business
cards cuttlebug Corgi it would be fun to
be on one of those games I'm one of the
celebrity if you were doing like a talk
show if it was one of the shows where
you can do games like balances games
yeah yeah you know competitions I feel
like that would be fun okay that's fair
good point
that'd be fun I don't know I said that's
fair so it's debating with you about
Katie Dubois has a facebook Instagram
maybe with some facial do something with
her YouTube channel who knows and
there's a show where she guest-starred
in three of the episodes me you him just
launched it's on YouTube you can go
check it out it's primarily a black cast
I'm trying to get at least one or two of
them on the channel I have nothing
against bringing three black folks on
it's just one or two just to introduce
some guests who knows maybe I like oh
how come when I talk about black people
I just immediately come across racist so
it's like my worry is don't sound racist
and then I end up saying things that
make me sound racist yeah well I'm
pretty sure it's a spoof of Fifty Shades
of Grey
I got that much okay good intelligence
to be a boy to be a boy by Ryan right
one day I realize I can make dick jokes
for a living and it dawned on me you
know I'm really good at making dick
jokes doctor one-for-one dick I have
confidence that they get there he can
handle it though she was able to handle
that space she really did the furniture
she's like Veronica man she had anything
I've broken many of things on her ass
she's not confirm ass don't firm ass
that's shaped her laptop on it audio
does not work on the computer anymore
very hard for her to edit man ass can
handle
spankings I'm not sure how to contribute
Moroccan never leaves me because I don't
think any your old one yeah Katie's on
social networks such as the Facebook
Catherine du Bois
Twitter's and the instagrams the
youtubes and she guest-starred in a web
series that just launched it's on
YouTube called me you and him which
ironically is primarily a black cast it
is though you will see a bunch of
characters from the board if you guys
watch the board on my channel so you'll
find them you have series also on my
channel so there's some white people
there is there's a great it's a very
diverse and fun now by diversity I mean
like black and white and that's it
there any Asians Hispanics yeah yeah
there are all those things and yeah
things they're people categories people
represented